the 14 moons of Neptune are a strange
Bunch most of them are small potato
shaped pieces of ice and rock some are
so far away from Neptune
that they need 29 years to circle
Neptune once almost all of them are
asteroids trapped by Neptune's gravity
99.5% of all the mass around Neptune is
concentrated in Triton it's the seventh
biggest moon and more massive than all
other known moons in the solar system
that are smaller than itself combined
its surface area is about as big as the
mainland of Russia and Australia
together but also Triton is one of only
four objects in the solar system that we
know is geologically active Triton
orbits Neptune in the wrong direction
against the rotation of Neptune which is
unique in our solar system for an object
as big as Triton we can conclude from
this that Triton hasn't always been a
moon of Neptune but probably was a dwarf
planet that was forced into submission
by Neptune when the solar system was
younger and more chaotic the most
popular theory here is that Triton was
once part of a double system when
Neptune migrated to the outer edges of
the solar system it's gravity interfered
with a double system and catapulted the
other object into space while Triton was
forced into orbit this would have
disrupted the orbits of other Neptune
moons rather violently and would most
likely have either pushed them away from
Neptune or let them collide or crash
into Neptune this would explain why
Neptune's moons are so dominated by
Triton
but this will end one day Triton is
being slowed down by Neptune and
eventually it will either crash into it
all be ground by Neptune's gravity into
a huge ring system similar to Saturn's
so don't buy real estate on Triton
[Music]